[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und einen
schönen guten Abend wünsche ich Ihnen
alles Wichtige vom Sport von Norbert
Lehmann einen schönen guten Abend
schauen wir auf unsere Themen
überraschende Reise in die USA der
ukrainische Präsident selenski ist na
Washington angekommen dort trifft er in
Kürze Präsident Weiden
von fossiler zu erneuerbarer Energie der
Ausbau der Windkraftanlagen kommt
allerdings kaum voran
und gesundes Essen auf dem Speiseplan
die Bundesregierung will weniger Zucker
und mehr Biokost in den Kantinen
[Musik]
erstmal zeigt Kriegsbeginn ist der
ukrainische Präsident selenskins Ausland
gereist gerade ist der in der Nähe der
Hauptstadt Washington gelandet ein
Treffen mit US-Präsident beiden steht
genauso auf dem Programm wie eine Rede
vor dem Kongress klar ist bereits die
USA werden der Ukraine das
Flugabwehrsystem liefern über den Besuch
selenskys
diese ukraine-flagge die ihm ein Soldat
beim frontbesuch überreichte will
selenski heute Joe Biden übergeben dass
er bei seinem ersten Auslandsbesuch seit
Kriegsbeginn nach Washington kommt zeigt
welchen Stellenwert die USA als
wichtigster Verbündete haben so sieht
der Entwurf des US-Haushalts für das
kommende Jahr weitere knapp 45
Milliarden Dollar an Hilfen für die
Ukraine vor ob der Kongress dem zustimmt
ist noch nicht sicher in den letzten
Monaten hatten zahlreiche Republikaner
die Höhe der Ukraine Hilfe kritisiert
schließlich habe man hier in den USA
genug eigene Probleme zu lösen
the days of die Tage an denen wir der
Ukraine unbegrenzte Geld- und
militärmittel zur Verfügung stellen sind
gezählt
wohl auch deshalb will sich selensky vor
den harten Wintermonaten die der Ukraine
bevorstehen diesmal persönlich an den
Kongress wenden
sowie vor Generationen Winston Churchill
hier stand wird auch Präsident silenski
heute hier stehen nicht nur als
Präsident sondern als Botschafter des
Friedens
zusätzlich zum Hilfspaket planen die USA
auch die Lieferung des modernen patreon
flugabwehrsystems an die Ukraine
natürlich nur zu Verteidigungszwecken
in knapp einer Stunde also empfängt Joe
Biden seinen Amtskollegen im Weißen Haus
im Anschluss ist selenskies Rede vor dem
Kongress geplant es geht um nicht
weniger als die Zukunft der Ukraine und
die Verteidigung ihrer Demokratie
die große Frage ist ja wieder Ukraine
Krieg beendet werden kann MRT Wissen
wird beiden selensky zu Verhandlung mit
Russland drängen
ein klares Nein aus dem Weißen Haus ein
sehr enger Berater von Joe Biden hat uns
Journalisten gesagt es werde Zitat kein
Drängeln es werde keinen anspornen und
noch nicht einmal ein anpieksen geben
das selenski jetzt eine
verhandlungsmöglichkeit suchen sollte
weil eben Wladimir Putin ganz offenbar
nicht bereit ist von Maximalforderungen
abzurücken man will der Ukraine die
bestmögliche Position für Verhandlungen
in Zukunft verschaffen und deswegen ist
es eben so wichtig dass dieses
Flugabwehrsystem Patrick wird geliefert
wird selenski ist vor wenigen Minuten
hier hinter uns im Gästehaus das Weißen
Hauses
und er hofft natürlich heute Abend auf
den Auftritt im
wenn mir leider gerade Tonprobleme dafür
müssen wir jetzt entschuldigen MRT
wissen ich hoffe Sie können uns noch
hören leider waren die letzten Sätze
abgebrochen vielleicht versuchen Sie es
noch mal kurz
in leider nicht richtig hören vielen
Dank trotzdem noch Washington el MRT wir
sind schon mal für diese Einschätzung
auch wenn es jetzt leider abrupt
abgebrochen werden musste wir werden uns
um die Tonstörung kümmern danke schön
ja welche Signale kommen aus Moskau am
Mittag die seit Tagen groß angekündigte
Rede des russischen Präsidenten vor
seiner Militärführung dort bekräftigte
Putin den Willen alle militärischen
Ziele in der Ukraine zu erreichen von
der mehlspitze forderte er eine
Verbesserung der militärischen
Leistungen in Ukraine insgesamt soll die
russische Armee aufgerüstet werden dafür
gebe es keine finanziellen
Beschränkungen Chef
und die Rede hat Christian sem für uns
verfolgt Christian welche Botschaft
wollte Putin senden
ja wladimir Putin hat heute noch mal
ganz klar betont dass er davon ausgeht
und dass er davon überzeugt ist dass
diese militärische spezialoperation
sowie der Krieg hier genannt wird dass
die mit einem Sieg für Russland endet
daran will Wladimir Putin keinen Zweifel
lassen koste es was es wolle wir haben
es eben schon kurz gehört bei der
weiteren Aufrüstung der Armee soll es ja
keine finanziellen Limits geben also da
will Russland alles reinwerfen was es
hat zumindest so heute die Ankündigung
von Putin ansonsten was den Besuch von
silenski in Washington angeht das wird
hier kritisch gesehen vor allem die
Lieferung des Patriot Abwehrsystems wird
hier kritisiert und als weitere
Eskalation beschrieben und auch als
mögliches militärisches Ziel für die
russische Armee also aus Russland kommen
heute keine persönlichen Töne im
Gegenteil Kuttin wollte der Welt heute
noch mal ganz klar zeigen dass Russland
in diesem Konflikt noch einen ganz
langen Atem hat danke für diese
Einschätzung Christian
Putins Auftritt selenskys Besuch in den
USA und die Lieferung des
patriot-systems darüber spricht ZDF
heute live ab 20 Uhr mit einem
Militärexperten in der ZDF heute App und
auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
der Krieg gegen Ukraine hat gezeigt dass
Deutschland unabhängiger werden muss von
fossilen Brennstoffen
unser Strom kommt im Moment fast zur
Hälfte aus erneuerbare Energie Kohle und
Atomkraft werden wegfallen gleichzeitig
wird der Stromverbrauch in den nächsten
Jahren wohl nach steigen und bis zu 15
Prozent wenn alle Autos elektrisch
fahren würden um weitere 10% könnte er
steigen wenn mehr Gebäude mit
Wärmepumpen geheizt werden gleichzeitig
stockt der Ausbau der Windkraft
Alexander röttich berichtet
Rotorblätter und Turbine fehlen noch
doch bald wird dieses Windrad dann
Niederrhein Strohm liefern wegen einer
komplexen
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung
verstrichen von der ersten Planung bis
heute 12 lange Jahre ein Extremfall sagt
milanitschke von der Betreiberfirma doch
zäh sind die Verfahren immer ist
natürlich eine extrem lange Zeit aber im
Schnitt sind es immer so fünf bis sieben
Jahre die man kalkulieren muss dass es
viel viel viel zu viel jetzt bremst auch
die Inflation die Energiewende der Bau
eines Windrades kostet deutlich mehr als
noch vor Jahren das verschreckt
Investoren
eine normale Windkraftanlage ist eine
Million teurer geworden im letzten Jahr
die Zinsen sind hochgegangen wo sie vor
dem Jahr noch für ein Prozent kriegten
zahlen Sie jetzt vier bis fünf und die
Wartungskosten werden teurer und das
gefährdet den Ausbau der bundversteigert
regelmäßig Lizenzen für Windstrom der
günstigste Anbieter bekommt den Zuschlag
es gibt aber auch einen Höchstpreis der
nicht überschritten werden darf
bei einer aktuellen Ausschreibung
sollten 1200 Megawatt Leistung im
nächsten Jahr hinzukommen das entspricht
240 Windrädern doch kaum jemand wollte
bieten also wurde auf 600 Megabad
reduziert am Ende standen Zusagen für
190 Megabad Leistung nicht mal ein
Sechstel des geplanten die ganze
Entwicklung ist dramatisch die Preise
haben sich aber nicht erhöht und
deswegen können kaum Firmen an
Ausschreibung teilnehmen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck bleibt
trotz dieser Rückschläge optimistisch
gemessen an dem wo wir vor einem Jahr
standen sind wir doch nimmt die Dynamik
zu gehen wir voran gehen die Zahlen nach
oben und mehr kann man glaube ich im
diesem ersten Jahr nicht verlangen und
erwarten sehr bunt will nur die
Höchstpreise in den Ausschreibungen
anheben um mehr Investoren zu gewinnen
gelingt das nicht sind die Ausbauziele
kaum zu schaffen
der Deutsche Städtetag hat angesichts
überfüllter Kliniken an die
niedergelassenen Ärztinnen und Ärzte
appelliert ihre Praxen länger zu öffnen
auch nach 18 Uhr und dann Feiertagen
verbandchef dedi sagte es sei zu
befürchten dass sich die Lage über
Weihnachten und Silvester weiter
zuspitze der Chef des ärzteverbands
Virchow Bund Heinrich bezeichnete den
Appell als unverschämt die Praxen seien
ebenso überlastet wie die Krankenhäuser
wer eine Geldstrafe nicht zahlt soll
dafür nicht mehr so lange ins Gefängnis
müssen konkret heißt das ein
taggefängnis entspricht künftig nicht
mehr einem sondern zwei Tage setzen
Geldstrafe die Zeit in der Gittern wird
also halbiert das hat das Kabinett heute
beschlossen weniger sogenannte
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe zum Beispiel für
Menschen die mehrfach ohne Fahrschein
erwischt werden Frank Buchwald
es betrifft Menschen wie Mario viele
Jahre obdachlos auch er hat schon im
Gefängnis gesessen wegen Schwarzfahrens
Geldstrafen konnte er nicht bezahlen
da aber soll sich nun etwas ändern
Justizminister Buschmann plant eine
Reform des Strafrechts
das ist eine historische Reform die
Resozialisierung stärkt die unsere
strafrechtspolitik ein Stück weit mehr
evidenzbasiert ausrichtet so sollen bei
nicht gezahlten Geldstrafen in Zukunft
die Ersatzfreiheitsstrafen halbiert
werden kein Knast mehr für Schwarzfahrer
Initiativen wie das Düsseldorfer
Straßenmagazin fifty-fifty kämpfen seit
Jahren darum die Neuregelung geht ihnen
nicht weit genug die meisten Menschen
die entweder schwarz fahren oder eben
danach auch diese Geldstrafe sich nicht
leisten können haben entweder psychische
Probleme so drogenabhängigkeiten sind
obdachlos Bedenken auch beim
Innenministerium die Erleichterungen kam
schließlich auch Straftätern zugute die
durchaus Zahlen könnten etwa
reichsbürgern deshalb soll die neue
Regelungen 3 Jahren überprüft werden
auch der Bundesrat muss doch zustimmen
in der Sache haben die Länder keine
Einwände billige aber werde es für sie
auch nicht wir finden diese Umrechnung
grundsätzlich nachvollziehbar wir
unterstützen sie aber
Körper kritisieren dass Herr Buschmann
hier Annahmen unterstellt was
Einspareffekte bei den Ländern betrifft
die einfach so nicht stimmen es geht
jedoch nicht nur um Erleichterungen
partnerschaftsgewalt vor allem gegen
Frauen soll künftig härter bestraft
werden ebenso wie Hasskriminalität wegen
sexueller Orientierung
Elon Musk will offenbar ernst machen und
tatsächlich als Chef von Twitter seinen
Hut nehmen ich werde als Geschäftsführer
zurücktreten sobald ich jemanden finde
der dumm genug ist den Job zu übernehmen
teilte Masken mit der Milliardär hatte
vorher auf Twitter eine Umfrage
initiiert in der eine Mehrheit für
seinen Rücktritt gestimmt hatte
im Kampf um hörlöhne und bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen streiken in England
und wählt jetzt auch Beschäftigte des
Rettungsdienstes 24 Stunden lang legen
Sie heute die Arbeit nieder die
Regierung ruft die Menschen auf alle
Aktivitäten zu vermeiden die zu einem
Rettungseinsatz führen könnten sie lehnt
Lohnerhöhungen zum Ausgleich der
Inflation ab wie von den Gewerkschaften
gefordert mehr von Andreas Stamm
wir wollen faire Bezahlung rufen Sie es
sei ein Streik erklärt die Regierung der
lebengefährde was die Rettungsteams im
Ausstand noch wütender macht neben seit
Jahren realen lohnverlusten bei nun 11%
Inflation dazu immer weniger Personal
schon jetzt leiden Patienten im kaputt
gespalten Gesundheitssystem zwei Stunden
wartet man in manchen Regionen nach
einem Herzinfarkt auf die
rettere Bezahlung werden wir 150
fehlende fahrerstellen nie besetzen
genauso wenig wie 47.000 offene
Krankenschwester und Pfleger stellen
bei akuten Notfällen rücken sie weiter
aus dazu helfen 750 Soldaten nur beim
Transport ohne medizinische Kenntnisse
ohne Blaulicht hilflose Gesten so die
Gewerkschaften von einer Regierung die
aktuell nicht mal an den
Verhandlungstisch wolle
mehr als die Inflationsrate dann müssten
wir den Pfleger 19% Zahlen deren
Forderung unmöglich das wären 10
Milliarden Pfund
verhärtete Fronten die Bevölkerung
mehrheitlich auf der Seite der
Streikenden
viel Glück in alle die heute einen
Krankenwagen brauchen aber die machen
einen guten Job haben das Recht zu
streiten
sie sind unterbezahlt das mag schwer
sein für die die einen Rettungswagen
brauchen ich unterstütze die Streikenden
spare in der Not erklären die das sei
vorbei weil immer mehr
Vollzeitbeschäftigte vom Verdienst nicht
mehr leben könnten
weitere Rückschlag für Donald Trump er
muss einen Teil seiner Steuerunterlagen
offenlegen entschied ein
Kongressausschuss das ist zwar in den
USA keine Pflicht aber Tradition der
zuständige Ausschuss veröffentlichte
bereits erste Daten demnach habe Trump
750 Dollar Steuern bezahlt 2018 und 2019
insgesamt 1,1 Millionen 2020 dagegen gar
nichts wie die Zahlen zu bewerten sind
unklar kritiker hatten dem
Ex-Präsidenten vorgeworfen etwas
verbergen zu wollen
weniger Fleisch Salz und Zucker mehr
Gemüse und Obst die Bundesregierung will
der Grundlagen dafür legen dass sich
jeder und jede unkompliziert gesund
ernähren kann denn sehr viele Menschen
in Deutschland sind zu dick zwei Drittel
der Männer die Hälfte der Frauen und
fast jedes sechste Kind sind
übergewichtig die Ernährungsstrategie
der Bundesregierung setzt vor allem in
den Kantinen an wenn ihr dummeier mit
einem Beispiel aus Göttingen
sie gehörten zu den ersten die Köche der
Göttinger uni-kantine servieren ihren
Studenten seit gut einem Jahr nur noch
vegetarisches und veganes
Essen täglich an dazu noch ein
Salatteller oder ein Salatschüssel und
das ist sehr gut angenommen worden von
den Studenten gesundes Essen für
möglichst viele das will die Regierung
mit ihrer Ernährungsstrategie nun
vorantreiben weniger Fleisch dafür mehr
pflanzliches sollen Kantinen auf die
Teller kommen mehr Bio und regionale
Produkte sind gefragt und die sollen
weniger Zucker Salz oder Fett enthalten
außerdem soll weniger essen im Müll
landen Waage bleibt allerdings wann und
wie die Pläne konkret werden erst Ende
nächsten Jahres soll das Bundeskabinett
die Ernährungsstrategie beschließen
das ist ein Hebel wie die Politik und
Beitrag dazu leisten kann dass jeder
Menschen diesem Land unabhängig vom
sozialen Hintergrund eine Chance hat
einmal am Tag gesundes Essen zu bekommen
gerade für Familien mit geringen
Einkommen sei es häufiger schwierig sich
gesund zu ernähren so Özdemir das
Schulessen sei darum besonders wichtig
der grünen Politiker fordert zudem ein
Verbot von Werbung für ungesunde
Lebensmittel die sich an Kinder unter 14
richtet Werbeverbote machen die Kinder
ja nicht schlankerl dafür ist das
kindliche Übergewicht einfach viel zu
komplex hat ganz viele Faktoren der
Verband der Kinder und jugendärzte
begrüßte heute die Pläne der Regierung
gerade die jüngsten kämpften oft
jahrelang mit den Folgen schlechter
Ernährung
heiter und unbeschwert so sind die
Geschichten von Barbara Noack eine der
erfolgreichsten Autorinnen der deutschen
Unterhaltungsliteratur jetzt ist sie im
Alter von 98 Jahren gestorben drei sind
einer zu viel oder die Zürcher Verlobung
mit ihrer lockeren Literatur traf Noack
in den Jahren nach den Zweiten Weltkrieg
den Nerv vieler Menschen sie schrieb
auch viele Drehbücher wie für die
erfolgreiche ZDF-Serie der Bastian darin
spielte horst Janson ein angehenden
Lehrer in München
jetzt zum Sport Norbert die Fußball-WM
ist vorbei aber die nächste
Weltmeisterschaft läuft schon die
dazwischen wieder die Pfeile im
legendären Londoner Ally Pelly gleich
drei Frauen haben dieses Jahr versucht
die Männerdomäne zumindest etwas
aufzumischen die letzte von ihnen fallen
in sherapie ist leider schon gestern
Abend ausgeschieden sie ist und bleibt
die Queen of the palace wird gefeiert
und im jubelt doch fallen sharuk
verschwand nach ihrer Niederlage schnell
die 28-Jährige Engländerin verlor gegen
Landsmann Ricky Evans mit 1 zu 3 doch
der Schwärm von ihr
ich wusste dass es hart wird sie ist so
gut Fällen war die bessere Spielerin ich
bin davon gekommen und damit glücklich
vor drei Jahren hatte Shahrukh als erste
Frau der Turniergeschichte zwei Spiele
gegen Männer gewonnen und sie ging
zunächst auch mit 1:0 nach setzen in
Führung verfehlte jedoch immer wieder
die doppelfelder und schaffte es beim
Stand von 1 zu 1 und 2 zu 2 nach links
nicht den dritten Satz zu gewinnen den
vierten Durchgang gab sie dann 2:0
Führung aus der Hand und verlor das
Match gegen Evans
beim skikross-weltcup in Südtirol haben
die DSV-Athleten die Podestplätze heute
deutlich verpasst bester Deutscher war
in Innichen Florian wilmsmann im gelben
Dress der im Halbfinale lange auf Kurs
für Platz 2 lag und damit kurz vor der
Final Qualifikation stand doch bei einem
Sprung fädelte er in ein Tor ein und
sieht aus im kleinen Finale sicherte er
sich dann aber noch den siebten Platz
Sieger der Österreicher Matthias Graf
der auch die Weltcup Gesamtwertung
anführt
und zum Schluss doch noch ein wirklich
allerallerletzter Blick auf die
Fußball-WM und zwar nach Marokko denn in
Rabatt haben sich gestern Abend die
Atlas Löwen bei der Fahrt im offenen Bus
durch die Hauptstadt von 10.000 Fans
feiern lassen danach Empfang beim König
höchstpersönlich aber nicht nur für das
Team sondern auch für alle Betreuer und
auch für die Mütter der Fußballhelden
mit Platz 4 ist Marokko die bislang
erfolgreichste afrikanische Mannschaft
bei einem WM-Turnier
und das war es vom Sport Dankeschön
Norbert wir schauen noch auf die
Lottozahlen
die Gewinnzahlen lauten 2 22 24 42 47 49
und die Superzahl ist die 1 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de
und im ZDF Text auf Seite 557
man kann es schon sagen mildes
Weihnachtswetter steht an mehr dazu
gleich von istanli das heute journal
können Sie um 21:45 Uhr sehen mit
Marietta Slomka und Morgen begrüßt Sie
hier Barbara Hellweg bis bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter typisches
Weihnachtstauwetter steht an von Westen
her erreicht uns sehr milde Luft
hauptsächlich die westlichen Landesteile
bekommen die zweistelligen Werte im
Osten bleibt es etwas kühler ja und dazu
gibt es viel Regen zum Beispiel auch in
der kommenden Nacht der verlagert sich
langsam nach Südosten hin und in den
frühstunde erreicht es eben auch den
südostner kann es glatt werden die Böden
sind ja noch relativ gefroren ganz im
Nordwesten da locker hat es schon wieder
auf bei tiefsten Temperaturen von -1°
hier eben mit Glätte möglich und acht
Grad entlang des Rheins sowie 9 Grad am
Oberrhein morgen dann viele Wolken und
viele reden die werden über das Land
getrieben ja und dazu auch Sturmböen und
die kommen aus Südwest im Norden ist es
nicht ganz so windig und da gibt's sogar
etwas Sonnenschein dazu wie bei
Temperaturen von 5 bis teils 14 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands das ist die
Temperatur Spanne die nächsten Tage es
geht mild weiter aber auch windig und
mit viel Regen am Freitag bis 15 Grad ja
und über die Weihnachtstage weiterhin
nass windig und recht mild ein schöner
Abend